Speaker 1: Let's go to Miranda. From where is
Miranda from? Is it send San Diego. I see S.A.
Miranda from S.A., Texas.
Okay. Where is SC? Texas.
Speaker 6: San Antonio.
Speaker 1:
San Antonio got beautiful. Great to have you on.
Miranda, you're on the air. But it seems
as though your connection leaves a little
bit to be desired. Let's see if we can
hear you if you try to say something.
Speaker 6: Can you hear me better?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 6: Okay, awesome. So I wanted to ask you,
what are your thought? I read an article recently
with the local news about Ted Cruz and how he's
basically a shoo in for his Senate seat. It's
up for reelection next year. And I just wanted
to know of you how you felt about Ted Cruz. And
basically they're saying there's really no
competitors to that seat and it's kind of
disappointing. You know, I did love battle and
I, you know, did a bunch of rallies with him
and went out there and met him, talked to him so
many times. And I really wish that he would run
again. I don't know if he would win because
he has lost, you know, multiple times. But
I would love if he ran again. I haven't really
heard of anybody else. No. So I don't know if
you've heard of anybody or if you have any hopes.
Speaker 1: Well, I always have hopes. It would
always be a delight to see Ted Cruz defeated.
You're right. Correctly assessing that battle
was one of the toughest challengers that one
could have in a Texas race. And Cruz is up
for reelection next year. I've not heard that
Beto is looking at running. There's I can't
think of anyone else for whom there is more
enthusiasm. And Beto also was not successful.
So that is a question when you say, well,
even someone as popular and well-liked as
Battle was not able to win. Is there anyone who
could defeat Ted Cruz? I don't know. You know,
it's I'm kind of withholding judgment and we've
still got some time and it would be a great thing.
But obviously, if I'm totally realistic with you,
it's going to be a tough 1 to 2 to win for sure.
Speaker 6: Right. You know, and I agree.
And you know that reading that article was
just kind of like so disappointing because I
don't understand how he's so well-liked in certain
areas. I mean, it just doesn't make sense. I don't
understand how anybody could be for Ted Cruz.
I mean, I don't really know what he's done for
us. But, you know, I get it. Everybody has their
people that they like. So I'm just hopeful that
maybe people will come forward and run again or we
can do hear of somebody, you know, great running.
Speaker 1: I'm with you. I'm it would be I mean,
I obviously eventually Ted Cruz will no longer
be in the Senate either because he will die or
he will quit or he will lose. You know, I
would love to see it be because he loses.
That would really be a great thing. But let's
see who presents themselves. Let's see who
shows up to face him in 2024.
Speaker 6: Thanks so much,
David. I really appreciate it. All right.
Speaker 1: Miranda from San Antonio,
great to hear from you. Let's take the quickest
of quick breaks. But if you're on the phone,
hang on, because I'm going to get right back to
calls in a moment. Let's get back to discord and
hear from some more people in the audience.
That's David Pakman dot com slash discord.